welcome back on problem number 10
10.
philip used four pieces of masking tape
each six
inches long so four pieces
each six inches
philip had a 300 foot
each six inches long to put up each of
his posters to put up each of his
posters okay so that's for each each for
this is per poster
good enough philip had a 300 foot roll
of masking tape when he started so he
starts with 300 feet
i can already tell you that
some unit conversion won't happen
because if you're talking about six
inches here and then talk about 300 feet
here
if no t no tape was wasted which of the
following represents the number of feet
and they underline it of masking tape
that was left on the roll after he put
up the end posters and they actually
tell us that 12 inches are equal to a
foot in case you aren't from this planet
so how do we do this
well how many let's see
after he put up n posters
so he's going to put up n posters
so he's going to start off well how much
tape will he use so for each of those
end posters how much will you use unless
let's con he uses four pieces
times six inches but we want to go into
feet right we don't know how many feet
are left so let's just convert
immediately to feet six inches is how
many six inches
is equal to how many feet
well it's half a foot right six over
twelve inches so it equals one half a
foot
so he does four pieces
for each poster
and each of those pieces is one half a
foot and now we are immediately in in
feet length so this is how much he uses
so he will use so four times one half is
just two
so he uses two n feet
so if he starts with 300
the amount that he has left is
what he started with minus what he used
he used 2n
2n feet so he starts with 300 feet minus
2n feet so that's the expression best
choice b
next problem
problem 11.
i'll switch to magenta
in the x y coordinate plane line m is
the reflection of line l about the x
axis
if the slope of m so m
slope
is equal to -4 5
what is the slope of l
so you should hopefully be able to do
this on the real exam without
having to draw it
or you could actually just draw a really
quick and dirty one and that actually
probably
would do the job for you
but let's so minus four over five that
means for every five
for every
and it's a reflection about the x-axis
so
let's draw a line m
so that means for every
so if i were to now let's just assume
that they have the origin zero they
don't tell us that but you know they
don't know it's not that so that's zero
one two three four five
this is
one two three four let me do it here one
two
three four i just want to draw it so you
understand
so 4
minus 4 this is 5.
so we know line m
for every
line m
for every 5 it goes to the right it goes
down 4. so this could be a legitimate
line m right here
could be like this
line m could look like that
right
so a reflection about the x-axis if i
were to reflect it about the x-axis
right this is the x-axis right here
so i'm just want to take its mirror
image or flip it over the x-axis it
would look like this
it would look like this
oh
i thought i was using the line tool
it would look like this
i'm still not using the line tool
now i'm using the line tool
it would look like that
right so what's the slope here
well
for every five i go to the right i move
up
i move up four
so change in y
and this is so let me make sure this is
line m this is line l so change in y
over change in x for line l
is equal to
change in y is positive four over
five
and that you shouldn't it shouldn't take
you that long
to do it one thing you could just do as
well
you could just draw a quick and dirty
one it's like well if i have something
with a negative slope
let's say i have a negative really
shallow slope like that
if i flip it it's going to have the same
slope but it's going to be a positive
slope but it's still going to be shallow
so it's going to be like the same
magnitude it'll just be
you know you'll flip the sign
so the answer is b 4 over 5. but i did
this just to give you the intuition
the next problem
or to let you know why you got it wrong
if you got it wrong anyway problem
number 12.
if n is equal to 3p
n is equal to 3p for what value of p
is n equal
to p
if n is value is
if n is equal to 3p
for what value of p
is n equal to p
this is kind of crazy
and and i just at first i was like what
are they saying and then i read one of
the choices because no matter what n is
equal to
3p
right there's there's no circumstance
well oh well
oh sorry i i was incorrect there is a
circumstance in which n is equal to
three b
for example you could say that you know
well
what's the circumstance
well you
you might initially say well as long as
as long as p is not zero
n is going to be exactly three times p
right
but then in our statement we i just told
you the answer they both can be zero if
p is 0 then 3 times 0
is 0. so there's no real algebra there
it's just kind of to realize that 0 is a
choice and if you looked at the choices
you'd immediately see choice a is 0. try
it out and you say oh well n is if p is
0 then n is also 0 so that n would equal
p
so next problem problem 13.
that was one of those problems that in
some ways are so easy that you waste
time on it making sure you didn't miss
something
let's
draw what they drew so you have a line
like that
i have a line like that
and then i have a line like that
and this is line
l this is y degrees
this is line m
this is
x degrees and this is line n
right here
in the figure above if z oh and they
tell us this is z right here this is z
and the figure above if z is equal to 30
z is equal to 30
z is equal to 30 what is the value of x
plus y
x plus y is what
well what can we figure out
what do we know about this angle right
here
it's supplementary to y right so this is
kind of the angle gain but we're going
to have a little bit more variables than
normal
it's supplementary to y so this is going
to be 180 minus y because y plus this
angle are going to have to equal 180
right
and for the exact same reason this angle
right here is 180
minus x
and what do we know we know this angle
plus this angle plus z is equal to 180.
so let's write that down this angle
minus y
plus this angle plus
minus x
plus z
plus z is equal to 180 because they're
all in the same triangle
so let's try our best to simplify this
well we could immediately let's see we
can immediately
and sorry we can really get rid of
the 180 one of the 180s on that side and
then that becomes zero
z is 30 right
so let's simplify it we get
minus y minus x
and then you have 180 plus 30
plus 210
is equal to zero
now let's add x and y to both sides i'm
kind of skipping a step you could add x
to both sides and then add y to both
sides but if you add x and y to both
sides you get 210
is equal to x plus y and that's the
answer they want to know what x plus y
is
and that is choice d
and so the trick here is really saying
well they only give us z the only thing
i know is z is in a triangle with this
angle and this angle
and let me express those two angles in
terms of x and y because they are
supplementary to x and y
see in the next video